labor wrapped up its conference in
Liverpool today and it's clear the party
has a spring in its step after a
well-received leader speech yesterday
and strong poll leads and all that
before more financial turbulence today
kirstama has called for the immediate
recall of parliament over the economic
crisis well we can speak now to the
Shady Shadow attorney general Emily at
Thornbury who joins us now thank you
very much for being on the program today
at Miss Thornbury I'm not sure if you
caught the whole of the interview with
Chris philp the main takeaway for me was
when I asked him if they were going to
change course he said no we're not
what'd you make of it
I know the complacency is just
extraordinary everybody else in the
country all commentators around the
world are unanimous in saying they have
made An Almighty mistake with our
economy
and they're just gonna blunder on what
we need is we need the government to
come back to Parliament it's the
appropriate place for them to come and
to reassure the markets that they have a
plan for for funding these tax cuts I
have to say why we're going through all
of this why are they trashing the
economy for the sake of one percent of
people getting more money on the back of
unfunded tax cards I don't know but in
any event they've spooked the markets
because of the way that they have been
talking it wasn't just what they did it
was also what they uh briefed they
briefed that they were going to go
further I thought it was interesting
that Chris Phelps didn't seem to be
talking about cutting the sorry bringing
in the personal allowance for higher
rate taxpayers which was something they
were briefing so perhaps they've gone
back on that but they're still talking
about they're not going to tell us how
they're going to pay for all this stuff
until the 23rd of November that and what
is going to happen in the meantime the
markets need reassuring what we're going
to see I think is quasi quartet you're
swanking onto the stage in Birmingham
for the Party Conference and telling us
all that everything is fine and the any
problems that there are are not his
fault and that he's doing the right
thing and I have 2 000 of the Tory
faithful telling him that he's right
whereas the rest of us will be holding
our heads in our hands and thinking what
are they doing there's one thing that I
don't understand right because Labor's
made a big deal of being the
economically credible uh party the party
of you know sound money of economic
discipline at your conference you were
talking there about unfunded tax cuts
fiscally irresponsible tax cuts but
labor would keep the 1p cut the basic
rate of income tax and you say that you
would reinstate the 45p rate but then
you would immediately spend that money
so that's not being fiscally responsible
either is it because you do exactly the
same thing in fiscal terms
so I think it's there's a number of
things let me just give me a moment to
answer it so the first thing is is that
unfortunately we fear that we're not I
mean hopefully we'll be in government in
two years time but it's two years and so
you the the 19 Pence tax rate will be
embedded by that stage into our our
fiscal system and frankly we haven't
gone into a single election and since
including 1997 saying that we were going
to raise the basic rate of tax that
isn't what we do it isn't what we're
about we're not about increasing the tax
burden on working people so it will have
been worked through by that stage the
question is really is how do they deal
with the emergency now you know the
emergency of their Creation with them
saying we're going to do this we're
going to do that we're going to do this
and it's all going to be on the back of
yet more borrowing a hint we may do more
hint we may start cutting public
services and this is just not the way
that you increase growth if you're going
to increase
borrowing you do it in order to properly
invest which doesn't mean a sugar rush
of giving tax cuts to the richest it
means doing things like we've said which
is setting up a Great British Energy
company that will be publicly owned and
they will increase the amount of energy
that we create within our own country so
that we're not dependent on Putin so
that we're able to get to Net Zero
faster and so we're able to push down
the energy bills I mean that's how you
ought to spend money that's what you
should be doing that's a kind of real
plan not what they're up to which is
just looking after their mates so given
that you say that you know the levels of
borrowing are uncomfortable given that
you say that labor doesn't want to go
into an election promising
um tax Rises for working people are you
also going to go into the next election
promising to spend more money on health
and education given there's no money no
more money left
so there's a number of things that we
have said already we've said as a
principle that we need to have a fair
attack system that we have at the moment
and we've begun to show the way in which
we would go so we would not be cutting
corporation tax for example
um and if they there wasn't the cut the
corporation tax then that would be 18
billion we would have a windfall on
those on those energy companies that at
the moment are making enormous profits
they were never expecting to make those
profits but on the back of what's
happening internationally prices have
gone up so much that they're making
whacking great profits and we've said
well we all have a windfall tax on them
the government for reasons which are
Beyond understanding are saying they're
not prepared to to tax these they have
insurance
they have introduced one window yeah
yeah but but since then the prices
continue to go up and will continue to
go up so their profits will continue to
go up and the person in charge of BP for
example says that it's like having a
cash machine you yeah when he's when
it's put to him which is one of the Tory
defenses which is oh well these
companies will stop investing if we tax
them too hard he says no no no we
continue investing okay so all of this
is nonsense we would change the non-dom
status and the rules in relation to that
that would make us uh three billion so
there's a series of things so we would
be doing differently to the government
and of course I mean the one thing I
agree with Christopher on is he says
every pound should count well done right
right I do until you squeeze one more
question in if I may because you and I
both been in Liverpool at Labor
conference I don't know if you agree
with me but it felt to me like the most
buoyant frankly labor conference that I
can remember in quite a long time and
there's been numerous polls of course
showing a rather healthy uh poll lead
for the labor party do you think you're
going to win the next election
yes I know be fine
I can't say yes or no because I don't
want to say anything for granted and I
know that here isn't either we really
want to have the opportunity to serve
and we will be asking the British public
in two years time okay thank you very
much indeed Emily Thornbury there for
the labor party